so I wanted to bring this to the part
about the media because it is very clear
they are sort of hinting that war is
a-comin uh and that there probably are
gonna be troops back down there as crazy
as that sounds so when Obama gave his
big speech about this last week he
actually before the speech that
afternoon at the White House in the
Roosevelt Room of the White House he had
an off-the-record meeting with a ton of
national journalists from Big Time
publications we've got a list of some of
them so he sat down with people from the
New York Times The Washington Post The
New Yorker the Atlantic the New Republic
the Dean of Columbia Journalism school
and the Wall Street Journal that's just
to name a few uh National Security
Advisor Susan Rice was there national
security advisor Ben Rhodes was there
and White House chief of staff Denis
McDonough were also attended and this
this is where I think everything's
interesting because forgetting the
specifics of war and what we can and
can't do and what we're gonna screw up
and fighting and all that stuff the
media how is this possibly okay that
before the president makes a major
address before he's even had a chance to
say what he's thinking he's already
talked to the heavy weights that are
gonna push the message out there why is
that okay first of all just to be very
clear for the record the only reason the
New Yorker that was there was that he
wanted to do a personal submission for
the cartoon caption contest yeah good
luck I did this is how visit an
Orwellian future that we live in um is
the the messaging to the nation is as
important as the actions were taking
more port of the target are you well yes
yes because well yes because they're
sometimes directly in conflict with each
other you know we want the leaders that
country out but we also don't want Isis
in so we're gonna arm the rebels so that
they'll fight Isis and that if we're
lucky they'll do that before they fight
the leaders that we also know whoever
they fight just as long as they're doing
something but from us yeah um but we
can't say that publicly yeah you know so
we have to say like a chart or something
yeah it gets very complicated their
arrows going in two directions you can't
expect people to multitask yeah you're
it
randolph first said you give me the
pictures will give you the war you know
and start the spanish-american war and
just because I'll Kabul you uh a war out
of nothing that's right so isn't this
though what what we should really be
outraged by look I know we can't just by
talking we can't control whether our
government is gonna send fighters across
the world but we have some control over
what word what our media is given us
right no we went with clicks and
something I mean should why aren't
people giving Obama for this he SAT
you know even this is pre messaging
before the message it's not even spin
after that's what ever you know that's
what I'm saying we always think it's
about spin after the spin room after
three spoon yeah but this is warps pre
spinning well in that case is called
putting English on it just say that to
say yeah but also I think it's very
important that you understand that we
are not limited to being outraged about
just one thing no I don't think this is
the one thing we need to be outraged
about all right I this goes on a large
pile of things to be outraged about here
and that I don't think this is new yeah
I think its new that we're aware of it
uh and the truth is Obama can't make a
damn move without being attacked for any
miss spoken word any uh syntactical
color eye color syntactical air skin
color bothers a lot of people um so why
going to why ways from taking a vacation
right uh golfing significantly less than
his predecessor correct I any of this is
is and what he really i believe wanted
to do in this case would sit down with
the huge media outlets and say look this
is the the essence of what i'm going to
be saying can we can you just understand
what it is that i'm saying and not come
back at me on how I say it if i stammer
but isn't is that not a direct conflict
with how the media even if they even if
what he's saying is correct or right or
what you believe in isn't that in direct
conflict with how a media should react
shouldn't they be reporting on what he
said not the private messaging that he
tells them before he
there could also very well be a tactical
purpose for it that there's certain data
they don't want out yet because they
don't want the other people seeing the
story and in which case that's a very
smart I get it like I get what you're
saying there and I this would be the
this is not the perfect time to to call
it i would say it afterwards point out
what's going on but up there in the
middle of a tactical operation yeah
they're their objective is to not let
all the data out to ruin the plan so
that everyone watches the story and
figures out what to do with it in
advance uh there is in the long run a
livery slope of we live in a world where
that kind of crap goes on in general
anyway I think that's larger issue but
in this case I can empathize with what
am I gonna do tell them was and hope
that they don't have a TV set they watch
the story I yeah first well I can't be
comfortable with the slippery slope
argument is one of the basic 6
fallacious arguments that are that every
debate student learns and I just I have
to throw that out all that this wasn't
your the guy though this was George W
Bush doing this you you wouldn't be
pissed off about it but you know I'm a
little pissed a little pissed off about
it but not overly pissed off because I
don't know what it was about yeah and
there has always been a certain amount
of on the record off the record yeah
we've always had that in the the
relationship between politicians and
journalists and this may be as simple as
he wanted to earn a little goodwill with
journalists by giving them some access
and having a private moment with them to
say look this is what's going on this is
what I'm doing this is why I'm doing it
yeah uh I don't know that I think it's
inherently evil or that so there was
some sort of duplicitous thing going on
there I just think it's kind interesting
that their pre spinning and I know they
they've done it before I'm edition so
final thought on this uh how do you guys
decide who you trust in the media
because that's the other thing when I'm
flicking cable news now and even when
I'm licking network news I'm like man I
don't know if any of this i just i dunno
they have me on a dylan on OC haha well
i know people can trust what we're doing
here but really how do you decide uh I
trust none of them wholly i watch all of
them with a skeptical eye and what I
constantly do regardless of what they're
telling me yeah is try to apply my own
moral compass to what I'm hearing yeah
well I that's exactly what I try to do
the same size same thing I know it's I
know it's the same thing right oh yeah
and also you just apply my moral compass
he calls i knows which way you're facing
north alright we're not lost III think
when you're watching any of these things
even MSNBC huge portion if it goes right
back into scaring the hell out of you
well you better be good or you go to
prison look at these guys and Joe in the
morning and there's a lot of right-wing
stuff on all the left wing things
ultimately I think when you can count
off the amount of commercials and there
are less vested interests in who else
because advertisers do modify snooze
content there's that there's the honesty
of the crowd-sourced you know people and
the young turks and you know going into
the new media sort of on your own a
little bit there's really uh it has
merit yeah so well that's why we only
have one ad playing before this and you
probably didn't even click it so or you
clicked away from it so there you can
believe us ok but just my own twitter
feed I don't trust that either